BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
Today, we're going to be
pretending that we're on Mars,
and we're going to use the
opportunity to explore sharing
from Android applications.
And before we dig into that
though, let me introduce
myself and those around
me, my co-hosts.
I'm Jennifer Murphy.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Google+
platform, which means I help you
build cool stuff with our
APIs, plug-ins, and
other things.
And joining me today is Julia.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Hi, everyone.
I am Julia Ferraioli.
I am a Developer Advocate
working mostly on
mobile these days.
And from behind the scenes until
this moment, Chirag is
also joining us.
CHIRAG SHAH: I'm also
most a Developer
Programs Engineer on mobile.
JENNY MURPHY: Thanks, Chirag.
You'll see his involvement
in a few minutes.
So without further ado, what do
you have to show us, Julia?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So with all
of the information going on
about Curiosity--
and I'm not talking about the
one that killed the cat.
I'm talking about the one
on Mars right now.
We thought it would be neat to
build an application that let
Curiosity share to its other
rover friends from its
application to Google+.
So we built an app that
lets it do that.
We thought we'd let it
do a couple things.
The first is simply sharing text
and some links to cool
images or Google+ pages.
And the second is how it can
actually direct those
particular share Intents,
as we call
them, to Google+ itself.
And the third is to let it
actually take pictures and
share those pictures
into Google+.
JENNY MURPHY: Sounds
really cool.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yeah.
OK, so should we look
at some of the code
that lets this happen?
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
We love code here.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: I know.
OK, so the first thing
that you'll see on
my code screen here--
this is [? emac's ?], is this
import statement for importing
the ShareCompat class from the
Android support library.
This is called ShareCompat.
This lets you easily build
share Intents within your
application with pictures, text,
and additionally, to, in
Google+, have attribution back
to your application when the
item is posted.
So it's pretty cool.
So here you'll see a standard
Android activity.
We call it Curiosity activity.
And down here, we have a one
particular function that
basically shares an image
from Curiosity.
We have a couple of arrays of
strings in our resources files
that have links to images and
some fun pre-specified
comments that you'll see
a little bit later.
So the first thing we're going
to do just to mix it up a
little bit is to select
a comment and
image at random here.
So you can see that nice random
number generator.
And then we're simply going to
use the intent builder inside
of ShareCompat to build
out our intent.
So this is where we're
constructing our share intent.
And we're simply going to take
that random comment and image
in the previous lines
and set the text to
that particular comment.
So that will open up the share
dialogue with the text
pre-filled as you set it.
Once we set the text type, in
here it's just plain text, and
grab the intent from the share
intent builder, we can fire
off the intent.
And we thought we'd
show you what that
looks like in our app.
So Chirag is going
to show you.
And as you can see, the
application picker popped up.
He selected Google+, and was
able to share an image that
popped up in the
bottom as well.
OK, so the next thing we're
going to do is show you how
you can effectively direct the
share intent to a particular
application.
In our case, we're going to
open up the Google+ app to
handle the intent.
So for that, we're just going
to share the Google+ page.
So we're going to build the
same sort of share intent
using the intent builder
in ShareCompat.
We're going to get a
string that says--
it talks about sharing
the Google+ page, the
NASA Google+ page.
And then we're going to add in
this line down here, called
setPackage.
And all we're doing is setting
it to the Google+ application
package on the Android phone.
And this allows the share intent
to be directed towards
the Google+ app.
So again, we're going
to start the intent.
We're going to fire it off
and show you what that
looks like as well.
So instead of going to the
application picker, the
Google+ share dialogue opened
up with the text and link
pre-specified there.
Now, you can also see that there
is a nice preview of the
link included in the post.
There's a little picture as
well as a description.
And that is drawn out of the
link and into the post and
attached in a rich fashion.
So once he sends it
off, it will be
shared into the stream.
Now, if you're looking at my
stream or my posts, you'll see
that it also tells you that each
post came from Curiosity,
I believe V1 and V2.
OK, so the last thing--
I mean, we need to let Curiosity
take some pictures
and send them across to its
rover friends, right?
So we will take a photo.
We'll let Curiosity take
a photo and share it.
So here you see this method,
takeAndSharePhoto.
We're simply going to let the
app use the camera on my phone
to take the photo.
So we're going to open up
a camera intent here.
We're going to tell it where
to store the file after it
takes the photo.
And then instead of saying
startActivity, we're actually
going to use startActivity for
result so we can get the data
back from the camera.
OK.
So how do we actually construct
the intent?
Well, if everything goes OK--
so Curiosity didn't cancel out
of the image or anything--
we're going to go ahead
and find the
file that was created.
And then we're going to
essentially get the path to
the file and use it in
the share intent.
We're also going to get a couple
comments to pre-fill
some text as well.
So then, when we construct the
share intent, again, we're
going to use the same
intent builder.
But you'll see a couple
extra things here.
In addition to setting the text,
we're also going to set
the stream.
And here it is.
We're going to parse out the URI
to the file that we took.
And we're going to set the type,
instead of being text
plain, we're going to set
it as an image jpeg.
Now, you could capture other
types of media, such as
videos, and just set the type
appropriately, and that would
be shared into Google+
as well.
So we're going to start it off
the same as we did before,
setting the package and
starting the activity.
Additionally, it's
good practice to
clean up after yourself.
So we're going to delete
the temp file as well.
If something should go wrong,
we're going to just let them
know that we had some trouble
connecting to Earth.
And we'll try again
another time.
So Chirag, do you want to show
us what that looks like?
JENNY MURPHY: That's a beautiful
simulated martian
landscape we have there.
Where did we gather
all that stuff?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: It was a
combination of skill and
whatever was in the
cubes around us.
JENNY MURPHY: I think I
recognize the sand from one of
the cafes nearby.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: I think it's
completely plausible.
JENNY MURPHY: I wonder
if they'll miss it.
Hopefully not.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Very life like.
Mars like.
So you can see the image
that Chirag captured--
or Curiosity, rather, captured
of the Martian landscape.
And once he clicks OK or the
check mark, it will be added
to the post.
And you can see a preview
attached to the post.
So once he shares it, it'll be
shared in that nice rich
fashion that you see photos
being shared on Google+ today,
nice and large, integrate
altogether, all around
experience.
So that's how to share text,
links, and media from your
Android application.
We think that Curiosity is going
to have a really good
time with this.
JENNY MURPHY: Some pretty
cool stuff.
So thanks a lot to Chirag for
filling in the role of
Curiosity on there.
That was pretty cool.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Yes.
How often can you say
you acted the
part of a Mars rover?
JENNY MURPHY: That's
very true.
So does Curiosity actually
run Android OS?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: I don't know.
I don't think so.
But hopefully, maybe
in the future.
JENNY MURPHY: It would
be pretty cool.
Maybe a future rover will
be green to match.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Little Androids
hopping around.
JENNY MURPHY: That would
be pretty cool.
So this is an Office Hours show,
so all of you out there
who are watching in the live
stream, feel free to ask us
questions, either on the
YouTube live stream--
Everyone, you may have noticed
we just had a short blip.
But we're back.
And we're going to repeat the
questions in case they didn't
make it to your screens.
So if you have any questions,
please feel free to ask them
either on the YouTube live
stream as a question, comment,
or on the Google+ event.
So if you have something
in mind, please ask.
So starting with Nicolette.
Nicolette asks about all
the Google messaging
services on her phone.
She has Google Voice, Google
Talk, Google+ Messenger.
She likes them a lot.
But she's a little confused
about so many of them, and she
wants them merged.
This is a great question
or comment.
And on this show, we usually
focus on the Google+ platform,
which means building software
and applications that use
Google+ APIs and tools.
So this isn't something we're a
great expert in, but we can
tell you how to get in touch
with the right experts.
There's a send feedback tool
that you can access on
plus.google.com.
You can also access it in your
mobile Google+ application.
And that automatically routes
your feedback, like this, to
the right team so that the
right people can see it.
I'll be sharing a link to
instructions on how to send
feedback in the show notes.
So grabbing the next question.
Oh yes, thanks very much
for that feedback.
So Gerwin has a question.
Gerwin heard about Google
Play services.
It was announced at Google I/O.
It seems really cool.
What is it, and when did
he start using it?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So Google Play
services, which we did
announce at I/O, is
still coming soon.
We're really excited to
get it out to you.
And as soon as is it's available
for you to start
developing with, we will
absolutely let you know.
However, what we've presented
today was ShareCompat.
That's available for you to
use basically right now.
So I'd recommend going out,
getting the Support Library,
and start developing and
incorporating that part into
your apps in the meanwhile.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So keep an eye on our blog
and on our Google+ page.
Whenever we announce something,
it shows up in both
those places.
And you will know right when
everyone else does.
Probably right when we do.
So I'm going to poke around
for some more questions.
And I don't actually see any
other questions out.
development with
Google+ today.
So thanks a lot to all of you
who asked questions, and
thanks for tuning in.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Thanks.
JENNY MURPHY: We're pretty much
wrapping it up for this
week's session of the Google+
platform Office Hours.
So remember, we have
them every week
with a different topic.
And we love to field
your questions.
So always, always have them
ready and in mind.
Thanks a lot.
Bye, everyone.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Bye.